uh have you heard from Lush at all it
looks like he's um he's relapsed ah yeah
I heard about that I haven't uh heard
from him uh a lot of people keep kind of
hitting me up asking if I'm want to have
them on the podcast and I'm kind of
considering it but yeah the the relapse
thing was kind of sad just because I had
so many conversations with him on camera
about him
basically moving you know or or like on
camera him talking about how important
it was for him to not relapse and how he
couldn't really handle smoking weed or
he couldn't handle drinking from time to
time or taking xans or whatever he's cop
to so far so yeah that's a little so you
would be open to maybe maybe having him
on just to I'm definitely not angry at
him in the way that I was at one point
you know but am I dying to rejuvenate
his career by having a conversation with
him because as soon as I started to
think about it I pictured him going home
and immediately doing a 5H hour live
stream talking about what we just talked
about on the podcast and then throughout
the next week going on 10 other podcasts
to talk about the fact that he just did
a podcast with me and I don't
necessarily know that I want to be the
one putting the battery in his back in
that regard but it would be it might
help him heal though it might help him
heal I feel like that's like a open
wound of his life because this the
biggest [__] that's ever come come up
for him yeah and he kind of fumbled it
you know he kind of [__] it up I think
that there was probably a time period
where if Lush had died I would have just
never said anything publicly yeah and
now I think that if Lush died I would
probably like tweet rip Lush so that's
growth that is growth that's a big step
right so who knows where we might be in
six months from now maybe I could
actually talk to him I don't know would
you uh ever I don't know about uh t-il
but would you ever entertain bring an ad
back on the podcast one day because it
feels like that's the one in
relationship that was I guess
as less disrespectful in terms of the
commentary back and forth ad kind of
yeah that would probably be plausible I
wouldn't be super shocked by that
happening I think that they're still
kind of like ganged up over there and
they just don't I think that probably if
ad did that everybody else would be
looking at him like he was bugging and I
think it's basically like both of us
trying to prove that not not just both
of us like me and AD but really
everybody's kind of trying to prove that
they don't need each other right so I
don't feel like I'm not really in the
where I want to like boost their [__] up
by I'm talk soon I'm talking about maybe
a [__] a year from now yeah yeah I mean
I feel like honestly probably someday
we'll just like see each other and end
up in a conversation or somebody there's
already like people in between us who
kind of mentioned it of like oh I could
get you guys on the phone or whatever
and I don't think either of us are super
eager to do it but I also has wack tried
no okay not so much maybe maybe to him
he doesn't really mentioned it to me
yeah I feel like Wax would be the guy
who would just be like I feel like he
would do it on camera though yeah like
I'mma call AD right now if he didn't do
it on camera he would go in clubhouse
and literally just tell everybody every
single thing that we talked about for
sure but uh yo is Clubhouse still
clubhouses I feel like it's wax house
now it's just it's just whack and like
10 other people I don't know he talks
about it like it's [__] huge but I've
realistically like almost never been on
there I I think the is that a pound of
mushrooms yeah I just had to ask I
couldn't tell if it was like pieces of
cardboard or it's uh obviously mushrooms
you put on pizza not anything of the
yeah Pizza mushrooms for sure yeah I
[__] forgot that sitting there it's a
lot of yeah I it's not that much that
would be a weird day right there eating
all of that if I that'd be a weird
[__] year eat a handful of that I'll
be on the moon are you are do you doing
shrooms uh at all uh I've done them
throughout my life I haven't done them
since they became like normalized like
you have't micro doed or nothing I think
the last time I did a serious amount of
mushrooms was like 2015 oh [__] so it's
been a while that was since then like
there's been a couple times where I took
a little candy or whatever like me and
sa baby famously had a little funny
shroom pod one time but I don't know it
was a little freaky to me I don't really
get when you did him in 2015 like were
you partying or were you by yourself or
the time I remember like damn we were in
the bay and we just there was a bunch of
BMX homies and we were just hanging out
in this [__] apartment just smoking
like infinite weed and just taking
mushrooms and freaking the [__] out and
then just going out riding the whole
next day and that was
kind of my whole life back then just
shrooming and riding bikes I don't know
if you should combine those two people
take shrooms as pre-workouts now that is
they'll do a micro do and then they'll
go work out to me I get sort of
self-conscious and fidgety this [__] bro
this [__] at the gas station what's it
called it's called Feel Free by the way
this this is this shit's supposed to be
like really it's like supposed to be
like [__] opiates plant-based herbal
supplement bro they talked about this on
Joe Rogan really I bought a bottle cuz I
was going to try it but then I I I read
about it and it's supposed to be like
addictive like opiate but it's supposed
to it's supposed to be like [__] meth
in a bottle but it has a like if you
take it too much you opat and meth are
very different I understand that but
it's supposed to have you super focused
but the addictive part of it like you
have withdrawals and [__] like um Jesse
who used to be with the nek boys was
telling me about it really he's like bro
I don't he's like I don't know he took
one right before he's like I'm addicted
to this [__] he's like I can't live off
of these they're at the [__] gas
station I miss getting [__] up so I
mean [__] is like right what's the name
of this [__] that's in here oh uh caval
leaf andum leaf so you're saying I take
that and I
doed and focused okay I haven't you took
half right how'd you
feel weren't you all [__] like I'm
taking some katum yeah taking a little
Crum so cuz I guess that [__] was
illegal for a long time uhuh and it
became legal and these guys are just
[__] these [__] are just slanging
this
[__] I just wonder what's worse that or
the honey pack P or the or the Rhino
juice that you get at the gas St I've
done a I've done a honey pack and a
rhino juice before was it
insane it works you know we take blueo
over here though promo Co boot Lake you
know what I me I'm all natural dude I
can't do it I can assume though if you
get to the point where like you know
you're 50 and you still got to get that
thing going you know what I mean I hope
that my uh survival isn't based on being
able to get a boner on camera by the
time I'm 50 but uh yeah I've never I
don't really have many problems on
camera so I'm trying not to jinx it by
taking [__] when the guys who do have
problems on camera do they usually take
Viagra or do they take like do they will
they do a honey pack I honestly have no
idea I actually had a porn star the
other day telling me that the honey pack
is fire it works yeah yeah it it doesn't
T it tastes [__] disgusting really
but they're readily available all over
La at every gas station so wow people
give me that [__] all the time I still
never took one see the whole thing is is
like I feel like nowadays it's more
acceptable for younger men to do that
[__] I know they're [__] crazy so I
have homies of mine who are like
dependent if they're gonna [__] they're
like I gotta get a honey pack I know I
know dudes who take Viagra every time
they [__] and it blows my mind like what
the [__] is wrong with you why would you
want to put yourself in that position
and so now every time you [__] it's
almost like it's a mental thing that you
think you're going to have to take
[__] Viagra yeah I was born horny one
of my home like one of my best friends
in the world he's he has he goes to
Mexico once a month and gets bottles of
viag and like for himself and I'm like
bro like that can't be good for your
heart I don't want to be relling on
anything I'm already relying on [__]
coffee and weed so
yeah are you still dieting yes [__] up
sometimes like I would be in chiseled
shape right now for the last six months
I had actually been on it but instead
you know what do you cuz you were doing
like the eggs every morning and yeah
I've been eating eggs you lost a lot of
weight eggs and bacon every morning for
like my whole [__] life but then I
have like a meal prep place that I use
but then you know I'll just [__] up like
last Saturday I ate a [__] Pine of
Ben and& Jerry's dude I'm opening a
pizza restaurant across street from PTO
really yeah and I just know I'm about to
you got a bunch of Partners on on that
or how's that look just just two okay
yeah you know I do yeah uh Armenian y
used to roll 80 he's one of my partners
oh that's dope and then um my my guy
who's a p the pizza man Justin La Piaza
I want to open a schwarma restaurant out
here I mean there's a lot of those yeah
but I feel like I could do it different
cuz I used to go to uh the Halal trucks
in New York yeah and they were so sick
and I feel like I've never found nothing
like that here I've never found one that
captured exactly what made those things
speci restaurant just call it Halal
truck it could be a brick and motor
that's a good brand name Halal truck
they have Halal Guys out here I think
that's part of the problem I love the
Halal [__] but it's not that popular out
here it's not [__] with New York no
there's nothing if you see if you see
100 food trucks out here 90 of them are
taco trucks 100% no if you you we're in
h Austin and they had the Halal trucks
on six Sixth Street right yeah oh really
I haven't had Austin Halal I mean it's
similar to New York you get the [__]
falafal [__] Peta I used to worship
that [__] no it's great no and then if
you you got to do it in the valley they
got a good Hal spot in uh in that's
really good my Jewish homie took me
there [__] was fire I order different
Hal places off Postmates from time to
time and Postmates ain't it man never
really hits the way I want it to I feel
like nothing on Postmates hits the way
you want it to it's always a little hot
or a little [__] cold it just gets
thrown in a like I never can do a salad
on Postmates but there are okay there
are certain things like uh what's it
called [__] nachos you would never
want to order nachos on Postmates right
because 20 minutes after the nachos come
out it's going to be [__] this is what
you do you turn the oven on W the shit's
on the way to you and then you throw
those nachos in the oven depends on if
you got sour cream on your nachos you
don't want sour cream in the oven what's
the oven going to do to the sour cream
it's just going to my sour cream cold
man yeah no that's a good point yeah but
you say no sour cream then you put your
own sour cream on after or sour cream on
the side boom no souram problem fixed